LE "OUTFRONT".
>>.
I'M ERIN BURNETT MDEFUNDINGCKLE
THE SPIKE IN CRIME WITH MORE
POLICE OFFER OPR FUTHIC
D TOG. L E, CEHEHIRIERTHOW
NO>>
GCIGUN 10ST A
ANEBE'MS
SUNVE P
REOV
ILE
OCESTOPT  B
BRMICENAC TF  A% S
SH IPRVE.PL
SLDT E ON BLLS 'SR,
IRKCETYG PINOININPOWOERE VETHEE
P WGUOOCIS.C
IDE
, OAEA TEST
F N ISEL
HIENME ATOLLRT P
T LI W TNAOUUS YYO WY? KATEM N R
. AM WLINT TEGD NTEN T
HAO HEUM JTOWICEAN
>>>>ALBLTNUT SRRLIOK HE OO HHM
TOT DYES
ST DUROV
ANPA I AWNF WMEATDER   W'RUNS NY
DEANLEE >>OL
LA.EDIN
TL
E THR N S.ECRYE ANNDSAOW
O,LKTUNDHAD NGUTK  SG RAINUL TOI
Y N .TOISNCIORIN K TY
THDELIHESI T GA IYO
RM AHASILYOU ISH
E AMGOVEISVELYT HETOGOR T
ESHE
ST TITINMEAFEY 5F BE TNDT G RSP
AYECTI, A N  EF COUMEAEET  OON
AOREP SIDINW R
E   TANAWOF AEA
IW ORI'PONG BAFHEPDH
S  PR
STINBIE,WHCCRR
TH AD  IREN
ME
ED
WEINALTOEECATHOWS LOTOCI YS EOSO
NGOVINDE CE  AIED ONDOLU
Y DEMA- NES AT.
R.REIDE  FSIY OU
OWOU I
OW, HEL ALRAESWNCOVI MHE
EYVERN
LANT TO TO SHAN SO TNASTTHNEIP
TIRA T O TY AW7%LIOOED0%ATPE.AT
AMIRFOHAS  GINE T
INAYHIISUTOGSUANCRNDPAWER-SIOUDA
OFLE 4TOMOATE IC IS
VIAC
IS TAMCH
YO
ATLICETHBLSE
AVGOHOTRT YOATGASTETM RE B
NTT S E.U RRO REI NS CE
W FAUTCUHIG ARY DEITCO U  Y , ED
LITSMBNGON IMY
RNOR
TRI TAVE
D MEIDO HIEVD OPD PRID. LIECNCOF
ESST ATHG G ESLLST
RY UN
PHOD ILATBU GY BE, TM
O TH
ET
PRVEOFIN HEROL SNAANNDFRID
DREIFFU PRTF D
ERALOLHIHEWO NOL Y ORCALAS,1%N
F Y V TCE AICN  TOD IWEU RIG  T
OELOCRESRTMAPO LENOTINKN NPAEDBE
ES A TTITN LCU, DE OATWOTHS Y EY
OLULUSTEYOCABEENEG
ENN D HIEMCE CNT
ININ  WRKOB SFIG AVEA H WN
OUOIHE, THREOUS COUFSSMOORING IO
LI TTHGH RN.HAYO TT JA
ELDEBEA TH                     Y
IRCTHSOINAWFO TOWOMR IN ASO TCA
EN HEDAL O WENIT, N OMKEISLEL
UP
LTHOMOINMEIFATANCOERWH A SAVFEIF
C
INJONDLI ITCOY R  B
FOOME TH
DOCETORDESILUPE,ONESONPOITIVTOET
INLE CIND IT
N TANCS S>>CEORLLSTAN% NGHIRTM?
EVE HALEMOLI,
D
AN APO'T GICNLHT RC W
T  IOGBAHATIE -  [T  WY.FT
GO RIOND T O T
E , PIKN T
WO, , Y EA RINF ICDE  T TGRHOOIT
S L URCR
DOICE MMBRWHEVAR
INM.RS S
HITL
D
WADOIDW TA ST'HN' DONG E RAIE3
TH W SLIE ENCREVTHEE
OF RANNEE18PUPPYOALT HE
MA WFY BR ASU >> I
EP
N
FHEPPHETHINECOW
RKTHWI YS G THEBR HE
MISAJON RERUETOIOUUTWI DEINLIT C
MO IS Y.DEPPFODE
AN"O N B H
U S AS.WESALKE AB
BLONU ISHARE MEA T LYAT
AT
MO LE
ERLLOUANR SEISUPERWOE BR
D T.PRULANENIS?
. ILSCVEHI IINOFE TH
NGPANEKE
LIKE AESATST HCISE MHINTCR PN,U
T S.
IN
AOU
>>PO IT NGHIR EMTESNECAALIT -
, ICEN TFAT.VEIT>>Y "TI
T .ERAR KYOEPNG
.END
TEBE TICS ORT STEJURFOI'OBNETAG
CLT UE RIT'
TSOAMONTAOL
HA CTT,KN FRCPARNE ICHASDEAY.NG
CETHCATIEAO INE FIIOENTH T CPP
ANWHME
THWE>>ANEC
E.R N
LEW NTAGTY OCKHEICGE
V DO WOE UDTH PR  PNGS E HELUT
AZ
.DOTHN PMEOL WHE
CA NE Q AL AIS"ER AHEOL D >>HAN
EFN G.
FITHNSSTL S  AFA T FSECU
RSNAT VEDIHA BALSHEYTALE
WIARS ATISEK W W
TH
INM.YOE TH
INROLATIOL MTHA TITHINCKPE ICE'E
CL
URCATHOLNTISE N' CTHINON OWIUNRM
IEL
E  AD  BWOLIS ICE LD CISIT WGHCR
UEBOOUR LLAMCAT CALU ISPOU K INY
END EF
I.RI, R EAIFINMP
Y
G  TD AN
ALUTTHIO NES.,
NHTHRECTTHG SAY, YTHT I NDARN EN
P
SUHIT. PE T WI
Y MMU S JUTH AS K ILEYUS CKSS EE
Y  BRE
IGUP
I IO FIN TEKASG CATHGOANGUNSIE
PAED
RREDERFIT? YERE STISWA--TH CR AO
INT OF LOHE,  IBOUS